a huge part of cpar is to not only meet
but regularly talk with share ideas with
the true luminaries of my field hi I'm
young so I'm a political scientist and
I'm a sea far as reality Global scholar
cfar has really allowed me to expand my
Global Network in several ways I get to
belong to a research program where I
have direct access to top senior
Scholars another way that cfar has
expanded my networks is through the
other Global Scholars many of them are
in the Natural Sciences and for these
people I you know I would never really
get to meet them naturally on my own so
it's been an amazing opportunity through
cfar to get to talk to them regularly
one huge benefit of being a cfar global
scholar is getting this unrestricted
research funding what that means for me
is that I can pursue much more ambitious
projects it actually helps me to apply
for larger grants later on so it allows
me to prove to other funding agencies
that I can take on these large projects
because I already you know have done it
through all of the resources that cfar
provides the unrestricted funding access
to the senior Scholars of my field and
related fields getting to meet all these
other peers in our Global Scholars
having professional development
workshops all of those resources put
together has just really Amplified you
know our initial potential into
something much greater
[Music]